well hello from davos again we'll swap I
run sustainability for Intel my last
video blog I said here are three things
you can do as an individual and I've got
one more for you today work with your
company to create a forum so every
employee can contribute now how to make
their lives more sustainable and how to
make your company more sustainable we're
hard at work at this and intelligence
and I've met multiple companies here in
Davos that have said the employee
involvement and the employee enthusiasm
has been unbridled here's an opportunity
for every employee of a company to help
themselves and to help their company do
a better job most of these are going to
result in savings to the environment and
economic savings of a sudden let's all
do that together it'll make a difference